to other world news now and the French
Catholic church has been hit by a new
scandal after a cardinal admitted to
sexually abusing a child Cardinal
Jean-Pierre Ricard confessed to
assaulting a 14 year old girl 35 years
ago he's withdrawn from his religious
duties these new Revelations come a year
after an investigation in to the French
Catholic Church unveiled widespread
abuse of children by priests let's bring
in Mark atsuruni who is the Europe
coordinator for survivors network of
those abused by priests he joins us from
Poe in the southwest of France thank you
so much for being on the program Mark
other church leaders have said that this
confession
was a shock what's your reaction
reaction could this really be such a
surprise to church leaders
well in a sense it was a surprise to uh
the French in general but I should add
to complete your report that uh this one
Cardinal was indeed found to have abused
a 14 year old 35 years ago but he was
just one among uh 11 Bishops who were
reported as having committed sexual
abuses over the last decades and this
came out yesterday during the annual
conference of the French Bishops
Association so it's just it's not just
one isolated incident it's a it's a
large number as I say of of Bishops in
other words people at the highest level
of the church were found to have
committed these atrocities
uh mark
given the large number of allegations
that are being made he is the only one
to confess and this is a man that only
retired from his position in 2019 and
presumably those other Bishops were
serving up until recently too what can
we make of that
yes you're absolutely right he's the
only one who came I was going to say
came clean and confessed the others have
not made public statements but it has to
be known by the church most of them
their crimes have been known for a
number of years and what's really
problematic and tragic is that the
church has been hiding
these uh uh accusations these uh crimes
and has been moving these Bishops around
from one Parish to the other just to
make sure the the information wouldn't
become public that's the real atrocity
here the way these people were not
removed from Ministry very often they
were protected including at the highest
level
Mark what impact will this conversion
have on the reputation of the Catholic
church in France I mean it's certainly
been in tatters of in recent years and
also has there been any response from
the Vatican
yes no I haven't heard any response from
the Vatican yeah and to give you the the
title of an article I wrote for my
Association I ask in the in the title of
the article I wrote on this subject is
this one more nail in the coffin and I
think that's a good way of describing it
uh these Revelations it's just one more
set of of accusations and also that
shows the Catholic church in a very bad
light in terms of always trying to
protect people trying to
um cover up the crimes in in ways that
are extremely damaging to the castle
true that's the thing that they don't
seem to to fully understand to fully
realize that their behavior is extremely
self-defeating well we really appreciate
your insights we do have to move on Mark
at Rooney the Europe coordinator for
survivor's network of those abused by
priests thank you